[Music]
gelila everything
[Applause]
you become champion this is not
everything you have to be greatest
outside everything is nothing you know
number one believe on your Wonka first
of all I want to sell hamdullah when
common this is everything I don't think
about fight because I believe Wonka
religion for me number one sport number
one so you're actually you were a
professional fighter for 15 how many do
15 years of professional fighter
tell us a little bit about about that
you know people you trained with and a
lot of brothers you know in our region
we have a lotta Muslim brothers they
fought all over the world and now they
represent us in UFC the biggest
organization of all well we just got the
Habib no magamaev who became the first
Muslim UFC champion in the history of
the world copied the eagle
suppose I want to sell hamdullah without
God we cannot do nothing everything is
nothing you know number one believe on
your one guy well yeah start training
when I was five years old it was
competing wrestling [ __ ] kickboxing
more time and then you know my friend
brought me over here and start finding
here professionally in Las Vegas
Colorado all over you know in Brazil and
you don't recently I maybe two years ago
I stopped fighting I decided to stop so
that was your your dream I mean you were
telling me about you know many people
don't understand the climate there is it
deca Stan Dagestan Chechnya you know
this is like a cook smart in this area
where little countries but a lot of
different languages different flags this
is the countries they just Republic of
the Russia because this was beckoned
into Soviet Union some hundreds come out
of the Soviet Union became their own
independent countries and some still
stay in Russia so this part of the
Russia you know I mean yeah there's a
lot of different countries like China
and Russia ata Dagestan Satya
kabardino-balkaria can shout jackc most
of this country probably 90% is Muslim
countries so yeah and there's a lot of
tough people come on over the best
athletes in the world is come out to
this region but you were telling me that
usually the people who end up turning
towards the fighting they don't have
many choices explain that to me because
this is you know this country you have
to know someone to get you know to get
the job or you have to have money to pay
to get the position you know it is very
difficult so there's a lot of criminals
over there or the people became an
athlete's to support their family
there's only way to make money and the
way they pay like celery in Russia in
example you can make a hundred bucks a
month tell me what is enough to pay
nothing you know 100 like in America
what are you gonna pay your gas if you
love the tank so like you know this is
difficult and a lot of people became a
fighters because you can make good
living you don't take
family support your family they don't do
this because this is fun a lot of
brothers know this Haram you know a lot
of brothers there's no other chain chain
you know they don't want they don't
choose it because they have to support
the family they have a big families you
know and all Muslims have a lot of
families and there's not like you just
take care of your mom and dad and your
brother you take care of your cousins
you take care of your third cousins any
take care of all of your neighbors you
know I mean so they give all the people
some of the other people you were
telling me that you've trained with was
that King mo but he's short as actually
I didn't know he's actually Muslim God
yeah brother yeah how about the other
pros the other brother Osama what's mine
Oman so a lot a lot of a lot of these up
why is it you know a lot of these these
martial artists these UFC fighters MMA
fighters they're courageous you know to
get in the cage and fight but why is it
sometimes you know they're they're not
it seems like they're apologetically
most they're not unapologetically Muslim
especially in this time this climate of
Islamophobia where you think you know
now show the courage that you are and
right you're you're a Muslim you're
proud to be one who has submitted his or
her will to the Almighty to to the
Creator most of the time but it is like
you know people who watch the media and
when you see the bearded brother you
know the first what they think is the
terrorist people man as soon as they
open their mouth and actually have a
kind of conversation with the Muslims
they understand this is a basic person
just like you
hey you know what I mean and we do the
same thing you know we worship the God
we we take care of our family we go to
work we come back home to our kids you
know so when you introduce yourself to
the people they actually hope in mind
and then you know but mostly people they
don't even meet the mr. Muslims they
know never talk to them but this brother
is day like this because most of our
movies have no knowledge about Islam at
all all they know is their grandparents
was Muslims they have a Muslim names and
that's all evolved you know they know
but if you know about Islam you go
deeper I was there too most of us was
Josh's back in the days we don't know
nothing when you know more about Islam
Allah open your heart and you Prague
because you
chosen one to became Muslim and
hamdulillah you know this is the
greatest gift Allah can give it to the
person when they know that they all
became proud you know the brother Mossad
backtick you know he was weak but when
he knows his roots and he started going
to the Masjid this was completely
different person he was became way more
religious than me I see him in every
fighter over there and all your mom
start telling me he seemed over there
every lecture is over there so Paola you
know when you get closer to Allah you
just crazy
yeah that's absolutely right when you
you build this confidence it's just like
someone who comes on the mat does
wrestling jujitsu they don't have the
confidence they don't know the
techniques right the more you grow in it
the more you're confident same thing
with with Islam where the more you dwell
into it the more you gain this
conviction that's it's indeed from the
Creator
right and then you're proud to represent
it you know and Muslims simply one for
those that haven't been tuning in is one
who submits their will to the crater you
weren't always a Muslim talk to us about
that
yeah born in the Christian family I
actually grew up in there well actually
my people was there was worship the
mountains the trees and the stuff like
that back in the day we have a big
history like aligning people some aliens
there's like huge history back in the
days you know people very very racist
and proud of their you know blood line
and all that stuff because this was like
back in the day this was a big warriors
and it was actually you know became the
Christians back in the days but we
always have a Muslim but little small
community back in Sabbath Union that was
trying to kill their religion at all as
a member one religion this was I was
trying to take the people away from
religion completely and I'm making them
focus make everybody equal everybody
here of all the communism so but now you
know the Islam is raising up over there
the brothers started going to the Masjid
stuff to learn more a lot of people
going and studying Mecca and Medina
you know and bring and you know a lot of
young people start to be proud of who
they are
well I grew up in the Christian family
very strong Christian family and I
started half adults because you know the
church do one thing in the Bible talk
about the different things like in
example Ten Commandments the first
commandment says the God only one so my
husband ordered the Train
become technologies in a new Testament
then asking about the second commandment
bother idols about the drying oldest
pictures this is a scene it's forbidden
okay let's go farther the Bible says you
not allowed to eat the swine so why they
eat the pork we're in the Bible even in
New Testament says you can do that then
there's a bunch of bunch of stuff the
woman have to cover her hair this is in
the Bible too and what actually in a
Russian Church what they do what was
confusing me woman covered their hair to
go to the church as soon they were
called it take the color out this
doesn't make no sense and a lot of stuff
they do they go and they worship the
idols they draw the pictures they come
to these pictures and say over this holy
days holy dead but the jesus never
taught this he never teach this and
there's no mention about this in the
Bible where he call himself was a
Christian where he called himself is
Jaeho witnesses or anything else so this
was my main concern I was asked you know
they even his name wasn't Jesus he was
issuing you know and I asked a lot of
people to show me original Bible if you
guys have it so I asked a lot of
questions they confused me so in this
way as my journey started master
browsing and learning a lot about Islam
and everything this makes sense this is
very simple God is one he creators he
sounds the guidance and tell us what to
do it's very simple and there's no
confusing it is no Trinity like train
one father son and somebody else and
there's no confusion they straight up
and forward clear so I became a Muslim a
little nut and that's exactly what
connects with the person who is sincere
he's genuine she's genuine they're
looking for the truth is this pure
monotheism that God like you said it's
only one worshipping the creator and not
the creation and this connects with the
heart you don't have to do a bunch of
mental gymnastics to try to make it you
know fit it's clear it makes sense has
the evidence and you have the Quran
temper free time for proof as we often
say it's a living miracle so what was it
now how did you get exposed to Islam and
what was it now you know the simple
message and how long did it take you
because there are a lot of people I'm
sure you talked to also a lot of
but now they're scared of like you know
the peer pressure what are people gonna
say you follow me all the negative hype
with the media even fighters people who
you often think are very courageous you
know I mean but now when it comes to
this you know they're like they don't
want to be associated with it so what
was it about Islam and was it something
that you you found the courage right
from the beginning to dwell right into
because you know when you started
getting close to a line you leave the
way he told you to leave you open your
heart and all the fear and everything in
your heart just disappear all you think
about is to make Allah happy and don't
worry about nothing else who think about
you whatever nothing matter only matter
what a lot of things about you and make
him happy
he sounded the he sent us to guidance
the Quran the Holy Quran when you read
it the front talking to you this is
living miracle
so much beautiful beautiful stuff in
this book if you read it it's just
mind-blowing you know and somehow Allah
when you know that when you know Allah
with you you feel it you know you see it
in your life you don't fear or scared or
nothing you said hamdulillah and you
represent your religion because every
person gonna judge you judge your
religion by you they looking at you and
they judge your religion the way you're
representing yourself the way you walk
in the way you dress in the way you're
talking the people gonna look and they
think about the Muslims so the Muslims
acting like that on the public this is
what they think about us when you
represent your religion the way the
prime Muhammad said he said I'll tell us
then we showed the beauty of this
religion so I encourage all the Muslims
your Muslims this blessing from the
Allah subhanAllah just think about the
creator of the universe he make you
being a Muslim amongst all that people
he choose you to be to be in the
paradise you know I miss you pal Allah
open your hearts and start learning and
be proud of your religion because
there's the most beautiful thing this
doesn't matter who thinks what and who
you know subhanAllah this we what we do
we pray five times a day we eat halal
food we treat the people nice we follow
all the commandments and it and they
consider us as a bad people and on
because we're doing all that things
doesn't matter who thinks what Allah
knows your heart or not Allah knows your
attention so there's nothing to fear of
it like I say this is a level of Iman in
every person
your Iman is very low you know this way
you all want this I'm in the media I'm a
superstar if I'm gonna start talking
about to God you know these days you
know how it is with the people when you
start talking about the God and kind of
push you away you know what I mean
because you know people healthy and
strong but as soon as when the airplane
and the airplane is about to crash even
at least scream god help me god help me
so then everybody's hard so like I say
this is all to make a dollar to the
people so they understand who they are
they understand their religion I have
you know talked to some brothers some
brothers gave this conclusion the
shaitaan' devil himself was a fallen
angel this came from the christianity
this is how misguided they are so how
can you talk to these people when they
don't know nothing about this religion
they were you know you tell them give me
translation on the Surat al-fatiha
they just pray this return Father they
don't even know what they say you have
to this obligation and you as a Muslim
to learn about your religion to
represent your religion and understand
what it is it's not just doing what your
parents teach you to do you know there's
not like brushing the teeth don't know
why you're brushing your teeth for you
have to learn your religion you have to
you have to know what you're doing it's
very important like I said this brothers
miscarriage because in Russia there's
different situation too when you have a
beard like this they already consider
you is a criminal you know what I mean
just by growing a beard but this is
hypocrisy because every one of them have
a little picture of the Jesus with a big
beard so here you have this picture and
you say he's the greatest man you guys
worship Him and then you see the person
with the beard like came dressed just
look look look on him leave the
lifestyle just like him you say he's the
dirty he's a terrorist
doesn't make sense to me so let's talk
about Ali let's talk a little bit about
the responsibility you mentioned that
the more you learned your Deen your
religion submission to the will of the
creator Allah Islam and you started to
implement it you actually your dream was
to be a UFC fighter yeah
and you gave that up and you mentioned
something in Arabic word that it was it
was something that was Haram
this is prohibited if this is something
now that we see a lot of what people
will perceive as violence there and
people tried to equate Muslims as being
violent this is not even you know and
many people they leave off like you have
fighting like you did in general because
of your religion that's profound you
left it because your religion prohibits
you from hitting another human being an
animal let alone a human being you know
doing any harm to him right so now this
is something that kind of goes opposite
to what's currently known but let's say
so talk to me about that what was it
that you finally okay because you
struggled with this for years you know
talk to me about this point when you do
something all your life and there's all
you know like today an example you have
a cell phone right trying to take the
cell phone away it's like you have no
hands so I learned this and this is all
I did in my life you know and just this
is just you have to give up on this this
is very difficult works especially for
the people who is in the high level and
superstars who cannot even walk away in
a street without getting out to a
girlfriend so this was difficult for me
but guess what when you learn about the
Islam they Allah open your heart and you
understand if you're a believer when you
see the red light and you know if you're
gonna drive through this red line you're
gonna get a ticket so why you think if
Allah tell you something this is harm is
forbidden for you and you don't do this
you think you're not gonna get punished
so why is that it's how can you consider
yourself as a believer if you don't do
what Allah tell you to do this is all
the reason and you say you love the
Prophet so it's these days you know when
you tell the people this is a Sunnah you
have to do this room to grow your beard
there's this fu all this Sunnah I don't
have to do it how you don't have to do
when the line the Quran says who do not
listen my prophets and it's Anna he
don't follow me he sent us as the
guidance he give us the prophets so we
can follow completely everything he
and teachers you know but MMA fighters
most of them this is very good brothers
you know they follow on everything but
like I say there's different different
countries different rules like an
example American fighters become what
they want to get famous because they
want to get money because they want to
get woman whatever it is you know my
people because they don't have no food
in the table because they want to feed
their family this way they have to do it
this is a different you know there's not
because they want to be famous and round
they don't need all that they need to
have money to take care of their mothers
and fathers brothers and sisters to give
them education like any other people to
take care of their wives and stuff like
this because there's no other income in
this countries it's very difficult to
run the business or do stuff like that
that's why they have to deal with it but
most of them is very religious brothers
and very good brothers who would
understand that you just want to get the
money and go out so let's talk for a few
about the people that okay they're not
at this moment gonna leave and let's say
okay you want to now you've gotten that
spot like the fame you've gotten that
visit you've gotten the belt let's say
like our dear brother our beloved
brother Habib right now what are you
gonna do with that you know that Allah
the Almighty he don't care about the UFC
belt he don't care about you know the
dunya he don't care what how many
championships you got but what are you
gonna do now to help share the message
to be the best example that you can be
especially when you have the whole world
literally fighting against Islam what
are you gonna do so what advice do you
have like for people like Habib now you
have the responsibility to not join in
with the conor mcgregor's you know what
I mean
get into the gangster things no but to
be a the best example that you can be so
people can now and now you know they
wear the Reebok you know the sponsorship
but now who's our sponsor are you brave
enough courageous enough to connect
everything that we do now what do you do
what's he going to do now they see you
praying hey I'm taking a timeout to
thank my Creator you know connect
everything back and remind people it's
not our job to convert anybody but to
remind to wake up what's in the human
being in the fitrah that you have a
creator you have a purpose so what
advice that we can like wake up and
motivate many of these brothers out
there who are doing it and they don't
have any plan on leaving anytime soon
but at least to go ahead and do the
Dowell hobby even in the first place
he's a very good role model for young
people as he grew up as a very good
person he's very religious if you see
him every fight he always greeting that
Allah he say a lie is number one I wanna
sell hamdullah
you know Allah always have better
parenting we have tomorrow
tomorrow God have plan inshallah doesn't
matter what's gonna happen I'm gonna go
keep forward keep going and make history
so thank you so much he's who give me
everything and there's nothing come from
it is everything come from Allah and he
always say hamdulillah he said Allah
Akbar and he never shame and he never
put his head down he always representing
always proud to be a Muslim when a lot
of other people putting their head downs
and stuff like this but a person his
position when he knows if he gonna talk
this way a lot of people gonna turn away
the fans and all this media and stuff he
don't care because he representing his
religion he's a good brother
insha'Allah he became here completion
everything in the sport with Kenny man
he became a UFC world champion you know
insha'Allah Allah will guide him and I'm
pretty sure you know he already do a lot
of good stuff what people don't do he
helps a lot of people he you know he
helps a lot he do a lot of stuff for a
lot of brothers you know he's a very
very good person and Shalala gonna guide
him and he's gonna be living this stuff
use this power you know the media power
the oldest like a bunch of followers and
people he's gonna make a Dawa inshallah
I ain't on a lot wheel and he's gonna
bring a lot of people to the straight
path and you know a lot of non-muslims
following him and Luke his lifestyle you
know they hear this words they hear how
he talked the way he treated people the
way he act they became interesting in
Islam too so this kind of Dowell like
Muhammad Ali did in his days back in the
days he did a lot of good stuff even
they tryna put the star with his name on
the floor in Hollywood and I know they
put it on the wall because he said I
don't want this because this name of my
prophet so they said ah so he did a lot
of good for the community you know so
inshallah all his brothers who is
looking over there and the fighted
brothers you know they're gonna open
their hearts and they're gonna
understand you know this dunya is
doesn't mean nothing is actually prison
for the believer
you know when insha'Allah they're gonna
open their hearts learn about Islam and
they're gonna use that you know use that
in expose and open up the human's eyes
to the religion of Islam to understand
the roots and the meaning and the real
Islam Allah
speaking of Dawa Muhammad Ali we've all
seen some of the the videos have you
seen where people are asking Muhammad
I'll leave what he's gonna do you know
with his life the remainder when he
retires and then he brilliantly you know
he goes into the amount of time that's
left in this world do the next 16 years
what's the best thing
get ready to meet God
owning real estate learning business
teaching boxes that won't get me to
heaven God is watching me
God is God don't praise me because I
beat your aging God all come about
you
so make these he goes into you know
working for his afterlife he sees those
opportunities because God has power of
all things if you believe in him
nothing even George Foreman will look
like a baby all the way into the end you
saw he was always you know someone who
is always God don't look at our colors
minds hearts have no color God look at
our minds and our actions and our deeds
so we have white Muslims Brown Muslims
or Muslims Allah Muslims all colors you
know when he was asked who was your
bodyguard did you see that why did you
do have a bodyguard
he hears the seagulls on the quiet
thoughts he stops those who say I carry
with me the matchbox all the time and
when my heart trying to sleep to the
scene I put the fire on my palm and I
feel this heat and I see I cannot even
handle this how I'm gonna handle the
Hellfire so this guy was brilliant
agenda I mean and that's why he still
remember to this day so I show how we
can motivate some of the brothers who
are out there who are courageous enough
to get in a cage and octagon even though
like you said they're going against was
pleasing to Allah but now inshallah they
had the courage to you know leave it off
but while they're there to actually help
to share to help to go ahead and to
raise some awareness and just thinking
about this brother can you imagine if
you encourage some people to learn sort
on Fatiha you know what I mean and read
this every day if you teach one person
can you imagine how many times is gonna
count you is American yeah how many
people are gonna became a Muslims and
you was the one who all that make you
reason for this person to became a
Muslim in your position subhanAllah you
can make so much good for this then you
know for this oh my you know for the
Muslim brothers because there's so many
people who is like you Roman for them
right now
they so proud the Muslim became a UFC
fighter this is a huge in this dunya you
know what I mean but like
subhanAllah you can do so much good for
that you know it just your brothers you
you dispo worry like I always I talk to
the brothers and I will still and make
it more that way in your social minute
you so much Allah made it easy look you
don't imagine if we had to go
door-to-door knocking on a thousand
doors to go ahead and share this message
but now with you got millions of that's
another great example through the social
media now Allah he made eight that you
can acquire a lot of you know bad deeds
or good deeds by sharing sharing out
here this simple message of motivation
encouragement for people to reflect and
think there was a fighter who out there
and it's amazing he got out and he had a
shirt how I love Jesus Muslims love
Jesus did you ever see that it was
circulating so little things like that
that you can do one you mentioned the
social media Habib you say he does this
in the Russian I do always in Russian he
mentioned it he always put the quotes on
the Quran he always say stuff you know I
mean yeah we support the brothers all
over the world you know there you know a
lot of people these days don't know talk
about the Syria because they scare the
mention but the kids die go there every
day
why does not mention we talk about the
Conor McGregor destroying the bus but we
don't talk about the kids dying every
day just yesterday this was a chemical
attack on Syria and I was seeing I was a
crying I'm a daught I'm a man you know I
was crying because I was little to see
little kids we don't have to be Muslims
we don't have to do we have to be human
beings when you see the kids dying how
cannot this touch your heart this
breaking my heart but Humanity is dumb
and people don't talk about this does
not you know the little kids was dying
from the chemical attack and nobody do
nothing about that but this little thing
happened somewhere I never up everybody
is talking about this there's enough man
Muslims have to talk we have to speak up
especially people now that have the
platforms that's amazing what you just
said like you know Conor McGregor and
that's another thing like that you as a
role model right now this person throw
is you know acting like you know pretend
gangster and whatnot like Burger King
chicken King whatever they came right
and now people we've already become like
this middle finger culture people don't
respect they're out there there's no
respect for authority but now you're a
role model people are looking up to you
you can set good trends are
bad trends and now you have people like
Conor McGregor obviously setting bad
trends you know that mean but now you as
a Muslim MMA fighter who's out there you
have a big following should be setting
good trends and being a good example
I'll be doing these days and this was
many brothers I know
Omari has made of Sultana leave gusano
mulatto Rashid Muhammad of all the
brothers who I don't mention sorry I
love you all my brothers they're all
doing a great job they all spread the
word of Islam you know what I mean they
fight but at least they do they part
they put the little seats in the heart
of the people and Allah will make it
grow you know sha Allah you're also I
had not - not too long ago I've had our
brother he's from from where where my
family's from Missha baptism and that
follows with me
it ain't no way no man can win no man I
feel like that somebody can definitely
relate to you know in a lot of ways I
was undefeated I remember did every
prayer every day went to mosques at
night and then I remember for my last
fight - I kind of got away from me and I
kind of questioned it sometimes but it
is I know it's not good and just uh just
hang him say that now it's like I'm God
maybe just woke me up a little bit I do
think differently now about a lot of
things right people like him also in
short law you know having he's he's an
up-and-coming and made you trade with
him right you know very well is there a
future champion up guy which I love but
somehow Allah is a very good brother you
see he get attached - he see the
brothers around here he see us praying
you get attached man now it's like I say
I see him in a Masjid more than myself
masha'Allah listen this really is I'm so
happy to hear that and so brothers like
him you know brother he's actually went
he's in is he now with training with
another Muslim Union in Canada he
changes the Hara yeah yeah so he's from
hala he's a good Muslim
- and dislike a lot of Muslims over
there you know they get close you know
brothers getting close to each other you
know you should have to be example and I
often say because you know when I talk
about being unapologetically Muslim it's
no you know we respect people of all
religions all faiths we're all brothers
and sisters in humanity but now there's
no doubt that Muslims there's a rise
it's a it's a quarter of a million
dollar industry bashing its mom fighting
against Muslim Islamophobia is on the
rise and that's why I say we need to
step up and be a legit eclis Muslim so
you are approachable you can get to know
us and see that Muslims aren't you know
terrorist Muslims aren't your boogeyman
coming to get you where people just like
you who want to live in peace with our
neighbors and we're open for you to ask
questions get to know us and connect
with us make the human connection
because you have a lot of misconceptions
and people who are out there distorting
the image of Islam and people who are
trying to create fear of Muslims so now
the people who are out there like the
Mossad beccaj and Eve and other fighters
King MO and all these guys shake changes
from o to Muhammad be good examples and
set a good example for others to follow
not just it's easy to be you know
falling in line with the conor
mcgregor's but to be someone like
Muhammad Ali the Malcolm X is people who
stood up for justice and civil rights
and you know like you said talk about
real issues like Syria Gaza people who
are dying you know to me while we're
over here you know enjoying you don't
have to talk about this to where you
don't stand up and talk for ourselves to
like you need to be stop being scared
you know shame you know like growing
your beard because you're gonna look
some type of different or stuff like
this know you're a Muslim you have to
represent you have to be proud and when
you're going to expose this religion to
the other people they they're not gonna
be fair to because all they see in the
media they scared when you show yourself
they're gonna open up and they're gonna
understand the real Islam and the truth
about this religion you know I was
punching people for living and I was you
know but who stopped me from doing that
they slammed the Dean you know the
religion of Islam would stop me because
it's forbidden by religion
I cannot hurt another human being that
God says in the Quran if you kill one
innocent person this
ikuo to humanity nobody say this corner
over there yeah holidays
I want to thank you brother thank you
for being with us here in the Dean show
this is our brother Ali from Dagestan or
satya this awesome
Ossetia and all the brothers tuning in
and if you haven't subscribed subscribe
already tune in every week to the Dean
show and the message is simple worship
the Creator not the creation he said
guidance over time messengers out of his
love and it's always been the same
message 1 God worship Him alone not his
creation do good deeds and prepare for
Jenna paradise avoid the Hellfire it's
there in the Quran temporary temper
prove a simple believable message we'll
see you next time peace be with you soon
like many people in your part of the
world Dagestan and other places in
Russia they've been asking me said
what's up with hobby where's he at he's
been on like I said every other show
except the Dean show maybe he don't
understand my english keep it humble
tell him how do you say it in your
language so we can make sure he got the
message
so now la cumbre be put to a progression
a show as a nurse brought on you well
show the girls in a shop up overly
complicated shemagh artists who seek to
bring of islam and he had a dream a city
where total more than you wanted to do
Bettina shall its most pretty talking
about its name you heard it Oh Polly got
you the message we hope to see you soon
brother Salam alaykoum dr. Apgar to